recently you you went online because
there was this discussion about Kodak
Black versus 21 Savage and your freshman
cover now
uh you had something to say about that
because you do have a uh I mean Panda's
a [ __ ] how many times Platinum oh man
it's um two-time Diamond eight times
Platinum
wow eight times Platinum yeah in the US
word that's so crazy but I saw you kind
of like put your like you know hey man
don't don't forget about me over here
you know what I mean and uh I was gonna
ask you like do you feel like you
somehow because I feel like you're
overlooked in terms of that freshman
class because you know your freestyle
was so legendary that you had to make a
record on Timmy Turner [ __ ] turn into a
record you know what I mean I don't
think anybody else had a freshman
freestyle that turned into an actual
song yeah bro it's love man I honestly
brought me I was banging on the fridge I
got I bring that you know I mean that
Talent from them you know I'm in the
neighborhood literally I was in the back
of clubs like Timmy Timmy Timmy Turner
yeah you wish for burner just doing in
the back of clubs and everybody was
going it was like yo bro what's that so
I just was like that day it was that
moment that time I was just like I'm
gonna bust it right here you know what
I'm saying I already knew and it turned
into a record yeah you won't sign where
I'll be like working on my [ __ ] you know
I mean saying in front of the people
always I'm always good with the
performance man I go a lot you put me
anywhere with the performance with that
oh trust me I've seen it man the way you
throw the mic up and yeah I saw you uh
real 923 we had a show in like 2017 I
think and then afterwards you did the
after party at Playhouse
you was doing [ __ ] with the mic and I
was just so impressed because most
people would drop it bust their lip you
had all kinds it was some rock star [ __ ]
going on I appreciate it love love yeah
your live Show's insane bro for sure for
sure